la plus exotique peut-être cap sur la
corse vue non pas du ciel mais de la mer
et rien de tel que le bateau pour
découvrir l'île de beauté des croisières
à la portée de tous on embarque pour les
îles lavezzi avec eléonore gay et rémy
passionnés
porto vecchio s'éloigne peu à peu et
déjà sur le pont chacun se prend à rêver
il suffit de fermer les yeux pour
s'imaginer petits mousses ou héroïne
d'un roman de pirate pour ses 80
touristes la sortie en mer c'est un peu
l'aventuré des vacances
première surprise la découverte d'un
littoral insoupçonnées
avec deux bateaux ça nous permet de voir
les criques tout ce qu'on ne voit pas de
la terre en voiture ça nous fait une
belle journée belle aux sorties c'est
super à l'extrême sud de la corse
la mer devient plus agitée vu d'en bas
la ville perchée semble s'accrocher
tombe mal à ses falaises 70 m de
calcaire qui se dérobe chaque jour un
peu plus
ils sont partis depuis près de trois
heures destination lille l'avait dit une
réserve naturelle mais aussi le théâtre
d'un épisode tragique il ya 150 ans la
sémillante frégate parti pour la guerre
de crimée a coulé corps et biens devancé
peut-il les 773 passagers ont péri les à
l'heure du repas bouillabaisse pour tous
ce n'est pas la catastrophe maritime que
les touristes heurter tempéra dieu et à
l'ambiance une pause à la plage avant de
reprendre la mer
depuis six ans le capitaine un ancien
pêcheur ne semble pas se lasser du
programme
ce qui me plaît dans ce métier c'est que
kim au monde est à égalité parce qu'ils
se retrouvent toujours mais sur un
morceau de moi là sur ce bateau
d'internet et à un moment ils sont
obligés de se parler
bientôt la fin d'une journée bien
remplie
presque trop pour se souvenir de tout
c'est à espérer mieux
mais si bing
il est 19 heures retour au port pour 50
euros
ces vacanciers ont découvert une course
plus sauvage qu'il ne l'imaginait